[Music]
in Forza Motorsport 7 the familiarity of
driving your favorite cars on beloved
tracks goes hand in hand with the joys
of discovery
it's about owning sporty cars price just
out of reach in real life there's
exhilaration driving on roads you
visited countless times and still
finding something new and whether you're
preoccupied with a pack of drive Attar's
or real life competitors four to seven
is abundant in different ways to compete
four to seven strips away the often
amusing ostentatious nosov motorsport
that decorated the series last few games
four to seven relies less on wooing you
with superficial spectacles and instead
lets the cars and courses speak for
themselves
this break from the ceremonious aspects
of motorsport is a welcome one
especially when all you want to do is
race the career mode alone encourages
you to get down to business in the wide
array of competitions spread across six
championship series since you don't need
to enter all the races to win the Cup
you're offered the flexibility to
compete with the types of cars your most
used to conversely the opening races do
remind you of forts a sevens vehicle
variety encouraging you to play outside
your comfort zone
[Music]
[Applause]
even after you finished a career mode
the quest to build a respectable
collection of cars goes on the draw of
browsing the hundreds of cards in four
to seven is the tease of purchasing a
new model like the 2017 Nissan GTR or
scratching that nostalgic itch with a
pacer X from the now-defunct American
Motors Corporation and while the recent
withdrawal of Lexus and Toyota
production models from racing games
leaves a void in this robust roster turn
10 helps cushion a blow with a hearty
selection of Porsches a manufacturer
that was missing from the launch version
of four to six
the friends as AI drive Attar's return
as a pleasing alternative to age-old cpu
racing behaviors like rubber-banding
online you'll find more often than not
disorderly strangers who are as impolite
as they are careless the alternative of
course is participating in private races
provided you can convince other friends
to do their best at avoiding crashes for
the least chaotic approach to measuring
and compare and greatness rivals
presents a host of tough yet worthwhile
asynchronous contests where you attempt
to beat other players lap times the last
couple forts of motorsports along with
forces 7 are engrossing due to their
true-to-life tracks and how surrounding
environments are enhanced by changes in
weather and time of day yet whereas 4 to
6 had a premade rain condition for
select tracks 4 to 7 has an impressive
16 variations of inclement weather like
thunder clouds and summer drizzle road
Atlanta on an overcast day can exude the
secluded quaintness of a course in the
UK like the Top Gear test track the
right combination of car and weather
conditions can give you a newfound
appreciation for a track you've raced on
hundreds of times in other games
what has always set for it's a
motorsport apart from other racing Sims
is the high degree of newcomer friendly
accessibility options many affords of
sevens challenges arise when you've
tweaked your settings just right so
first place wins are hard-fought and
with the return of mod cards originally
introduced in Forza Motorsport 6 you can
self impose other performance incentives
for greater rewards mods are unlocked as
part of ports a sevens blind card system
known as prize crates
these packs evenly mix practical items
like cars and mods with cosmetic goods
such as badges and driver outfits after
opening a dozen packs I felt like I
broke even feeling elation when spending
little twin a rare car as well as
heartbreak for buying the most expensive
crate and ending up with only common
items while cars are now organized by
loot inspired rarity based on the price
ranges you can still buy cars no matter
the rarity without relying on the
uncertainty of chance with the prize
crates
by the time I had logged on a couple
dozen hours and four to seven the
confluence of environmental and driving
realism unexpectedly inspired me to
recreate real-life racing events like
the famous 1996 is an RD pass at Laguna
Seca these are the kinds of experiments
four to seven inspires thanks in part to
the game's variety and flexibility even
with an imperfect roster and a selection
of modes it doesn't compare to the
comprehensiveness of Forza 6 at launch
forza motorsport 7 is still a
feature-rich and competition diverse
bundle of racing events that keep you
coming back for more the ability to
control the weather to create rich
painterly cloudy backdrops goes a long
way in making up for the lack of zombie
modes and the toyota mr2
[Applause]
you